hello I'm Sam
hello I am Rafiq we are here to discover
I know that I'm from you doing
this church remains the ruins and the
damages of the second world so but I
think that it also make us remember the
they suffer but yeah
are you now so have a quickly to the
Royal Guard
this new thing in Tunisia we haven't
gotten with the statues
though are you not using to act like
these you have paintings it's the first
time it's any time that I saw some
unusual art we are stuck to our religion
but we are also over reminded yes yes we
are open-minded we are here to discover
new attitudes to her know how people are
think think yes thinking yes
the main thing we do here is whole
church services they're always on
Sundays not on Fridays Sunday morning
and evening that's the yeah the most
impressive thing that I discovered since
I came in usuals in our new religions
knew how to pray how to deal with
religion here
Oh what's this it's very big
five
Honora is just forests you can say in
the module we have bought small trees
mostly serious little bit the forests
are not too big like this
here we are
we spent a good day in Hannover and I
hope that you enjoy it with us so and
now if you have to go go back
you